here
live with dr shep dolmen who is a friend
of the show past guest on the show
uh talking about the previous phenomenal
discovery by the event horizon telescope
today's announcement
really shook up my universe the universe
of those who care about monsters and
incredible gravitational discoveries but
shep
take it away what did you uh your team
announced today this is so phenomenal
it was it was a pretty incredible day
brian but today we announced the first
image of the supermassive black hole in
the center of our galaxy sagittarius a
star
it's it's at the same time
very similar but also quite different
from the black hole we imaged in 2019
that was m87 which weighed six and a
half billion solar masses so let's first
talk about why they're the same
no matter how you light up the space
time around a black hole the intense
gravity
dictates what the image is going to look
like so
these black holes are surrounded by an
ultra hot plasma it's radiating light
across the electromagnetic spectrum and
it's bent by einstein's gravity into
this ring shape so the fact that we saw
a ring in m87 and we saw one
in sagittarius star which are different
in mass by about a factor of a thousand
is another confirmation of einstein's
theory of gravity that these black holes
all bent light in exactly the same way
and appear the same
now they're different
because m87 is a monster
m87 is one of the biggest black holes we
know of in the universe
and it has a jet
that is powered by the black hole
piercing the entire galaxy whereas
sanjay starr is the timidest of eaters
it is just eating a tiny tiny amount uh
at the press conference today michael
johnson said that if sanjay star were a
human
they would be eating one grain of rice
every million years or so i mean that's
the that's the rate at which sagittarius
a star is delicately consuming the gas
around it so it's not a monster
what makes it so special is it's our
monster and we can use its proximity to
study it in a way that we can't
necessarily study m87 so it's a great
day for black holes that they're the
same but also that we have a completely
different black hole to study them
and the shape of the black hole it looks
you know i was kind of anticipating this
would be about the um the black hole the
milky way galaxy but the shape and the
morphology looks so radically different
from the m87 black hole is that purely
attributable to its mass
well it's partially the mass but also
mostly
at this point it's due to the fact that
sagittarius a star weighs a thousand
times less so that means that the
dynamical time scale
the
uh the rate at which it changes
is a thousand times faster so while
we're observing sagittarius a star it's
changing
while we're trying to capture its image
that means that the the quality of the
image is poorer it's like trying to
capture
a running person
with in a time exposure a long time
exposure it gets very blurry
so the fact that it looks a little
different but there are blobs around the
ring
is mostly a consequence of the fact is
changing
while we're looking at it
and not so much that it's intrinsically
much much different
now this is a good thing right because
this tells us that
when we want to you know when we talk
about making movies of black holes we
now have
our leading actor right sagittarius a
star is the one that we want to make a
movie of because it changes on these
very very short time scales uh for m87
we would take snapshots every few weeks
and tie years of observation into a
time-lapse movie with sagi star we can
see evolve
in real time
so so again the images are a little bit
different
a little bit the same and it all speaks
to the fundamental physics around black
holes
will we also expect to get more
information in the coming years from
this black hole are we still taking are
you still taking data with the
eht currently on this object yeah
absolutely so so for example we've
learned some things right away
from this treasure trove of data
uh you know first
four and a half million solar masses
are
within the photon orbit right this is
the strongest evidence
for the existence of the supermassive
black hole in the center of our galaxy
full stop
in 2020 reinhardt guentzel and andre
iges won the nobel prize
for
determining that there was a compact
object
at the galactic center but the nobel
prize committee stopped short of saying
it was a black hole
now we have the proof the long sought
proof that
the object at the center of our galaxy
is indeed a black hole there's there's
no other way for us to get that
particular ring
that matches
the mass derived by
denzel and and guess at 4 million solar
masses everything fits together now it
paints a wonderful picture
but you asked about what
what comes next and what we're learning
so for example looking at the
simulations of black holes we can now
say
that there are
likely strong magnetic fields operating
close to sagittarius a star we can say
that
uh the temperature of the electrons is
probably pretty high compared to the
temperature of the ions it's something
that people who study accretion are very
interested in and
and we can also say that the time
variability seems to match generally
what we might expect it's actually
sagittarius a star seems to be a little
quieter
than all of our computer models might
suggest so when you run these computer
models on banks of cpus
uh they predict that sagittarius star
would be a little more jumpy
a little more frantic a little more
puppy-ish
and the sagittarius the sagi star
object that we actually observed seems
to be a little calmer so that's
something for us to really dig into
over the coming years and we have data
in the cam
from a couple of other epics and we're
building the instrument out all the time
and the next generation phd will make
true movies of saging star
yeah i want to get to that in in a bit
uh i noticed you have a new button uh on
your lapel you had uh you had a previous
one last time so if people can find
their lapel manufacturer then they'll be
able to get data you know uh in in real
time uh just kidding um but um
but in seriousness when we look at the
when we look at the um the black hole
image from a m87 and we look at the
black hole now image that you produced
with your team for a uh from the sage
star we see you know there's no scale
there's no way to tell just from the
lapel pin you know are they the same
size of course they're not uh this one
is
you know maybe 500 times less massive um
but what what do we learn about the
sense of scale and perhaps uh the
orientation uh because the black hole
you know could be in any orientation and
was it just fortuitous that they seem to
present the same
general morphology and they're circular
obviously there's a shadow there's a
there's a dark spot um was that
fortuitous or or is that something else
yeah so
yeah you've hit the nail on the head
there brian so it turns out that
because the ring seems to be
roughly uniform or the all like the
north of the of the ring is as bright as
the south part of the ring there are
lumps
but there's no clear asymmetry from one
side to another
of the sanjay star result that tells us
that we're probably looking at it face
on
and that's that is very interesting
because consider for a moment
that we live in an outer arm of the
milky way galaxy so if the spin of the
black hole was aligned with the rotation
of the milky way
we would be looking at sagittarius a
star edge on it does not look
like we are seeing an edge-on black hole
that means that the black hole for some
reason seems to be pointed not far
from our line of sight
now that's a mystery
and that's what we're going to have to
resolve over the coming years why is
that there's a little bit of evidence
from
uh the optical and infrared groups that
suggest also that we should be seeing it
face on so this is consistent with that
but another mystery like why are we in
this preferred direction yeah from the
galactic center
uh so
that just speaks to your question about
why it kind of looks the way it does but
in terms of scale
now let's talk monsters brian
the the m87 black hole is six and a half
billion solar masses
it's the size of the entire solar system
our entire solar system could fit many
times over in the shadow of that black
hole so to keep that in your mind for a
moment
sagittarii is a star though it appears
the same size on the sky because it's
closer is actually about 1500 times less
massive
the event horizon and shadow of sanjay
star would fit
well within the orbit of mercury in our
own solar system
right so you're looking at something
that snuggly fits close to the sun
versus something that could swallow the
solar system many times over
and the fact that we're seeing
these black holes that appear the same
skies
reinforces the idea that black holes are
the same no matter what size they are no
matter what mass they are
the ones that discovered by ligo there
are 10 solar masses
seem to be the same as the ones
the sage star which is a four million
solar masses and one that's six and a
half billion
there's no other object in the universe
that exists in it in a single form
at all those different scales if you
took a mouse
and you tried to scale a mouse up a
billion times it would collapse under
its own weight right a mouse can't be a
billion times the size of a mouse its
skeleton doesn't scale properly right
but a black hole
is perfectly at home no matter what mass
it is
that's incredible yeah they are the
biggest objects single objects in the uh
in the universe they've been around for
a long time i made a video on my channel
today or i talked about you know could
they make up for the dark matter in the
universe and before we get to that
uh i want to ask uh behind me is a
picture i'll put on that side uh of m 51
which is the whirlpool galaxy it's a
galaxy not unlike
the milky way but m87 is is an irregular
or elliptical galaxy it's very different
could that be in part why we see these
blobs are these the you know the the
blobs that uh andrea and reinhard call
you know these uh a2 and
are those blobs that we're seeing in the
image are they anyway related to the
clumps of gas and dust and star forming
and start dying regions in our galaxy
are they completely different yeah
they are very different it also helps to
make a jump to the scale here so the the
tremendous
you know pioneering work by by andre
igez and reinhard genzel show the orbits
of stars around an unseen mouse that
compact object that we talked about
earlier
and
the the closest point of approach of
those stars is still
about a thousand times bigger than the
shadow we observed today
in other words if newton saw the motion
of these stars
around the black hole he would not be
surprised you have to look very very
carefully at the motions of those stars
to discern any hint of einstein and
general relativity
whereas we're so close
that everything is governed by
tens of billions of degree gases
emitting light is bent like taffy in the
gravity of the black hole so totally
different
origin of those blobs
much much closer by a factor of about a
thousand
amazing
um i want to ask a question that you
know lay people want to know oftentimes
they people ask me what do you you know
hope to see with with the simon's
observatory or or any other project and
i always say i don't like to think about
what i hope to see what i you know what
i want to see because that can lead to
confirmation bias et cetera in this case
you must have known for a long time that
this was going to happen and you must
have been excited to see it in some
sense talk about how did this
emotionally resonate with you um if at
all you know we scientists are are human
beings despite the stereotypes of the
contrary how did this culmination of
your planning with your colleagues for
decades um and fighting for funding and
fighting for scarce resources how does
it feel to make this image of something
that would blow the minds of someone
as great as einstein or newton or
anybody how does it feel just on a
personal level i'm curious
you know a lot of different emotions are
running through us like awe you know
humility relief
and inspiration
you said something very interesting
about
einstein and how his mind would be blown
the more i've been in this game and i've
been chasing
sanjay starr for over 25 years now
the more i think about it the more it's
about connections
we have a connection historically
i call it the 100 year handshake with
einstein and schwarzschild
you know we're continuing their
tradition
and every day we talk about the einstein
equations every day we talk about the
schwarzschild radius
it's not
it's not
a fabrication right it's not posturing
like we we dip into those deep
traditional scientific wells every
single day
and to be able to take the next step
like this with this amazing team
is a fulfillment not just of of my
personal dream but also of the dream of
all scientists that we all build on the
work of each other
to address these big questions so it's
it's being part of
of a hundred year process
that gives the depth of it the richness
of it the texture of it
that's what i find most
comforting
and and
and most incredible about this whole
journey that and being able to work with
this team i mean this
the people involved in this project are
just incredible
and you talked about the future let's go
uh before we get to the future for the
next generation which i'm uh thrilled to
hear about um when we spoke uh last time
it was it was in between i spoke to hino
falca and others about the polarization
results do we can we expect polarization
results from the milky way galaxies
black hole sagi star and if so what will
that tell us
absolutely
we already know just from some of the
brightness
not not the polarization but the
brightness that there are likely strong
ordered magnetic fields
around sagittarius they start but we
haven't mapped them yet
that will be the next
uh project for the eht that and then
looking at even
more data with better arrays so right
now we have a hint
that things are changing
we in fact we know they're changing we
can see from the raw data that things
are jumping around but we can't form a
movie yet we cannot make a movie of
sagittarius a star so it's like we know
something's moving
can't make it out
but in the future we'll be able to
advance our algorithms
and
build out the array to capture that
motion so
over the coming years we'll look at new
data sets
look for polarization but also look for
this motion
and that's that and that's what
differentiates m87 from star um we'll be
able to catch
the black hole in motion with
sagittarius a star so that's really what
motivates us to build the next
generation
will that have more to teach us about
astrophysics when these movies are made
or we'll teach us more about gravity or
all of the above
so so it turns out both
what we're really after
is is kind of two-fold
one is
how do these black holes launch jets
and how do they
interact with the
matter that's circling them and
understanding that will tell us how
black holes feed
how they're in symbiosis with the
galaxies that host them
and how they can disrupt potentially
star formation in those galaxies in
other words how the large-scale
structure that we see in the night sky
evolves
at the same time
we know that these
rings that we see
have substructure
some of the light is gently bent to us
but some does a u-turn
some does a full orbit around it
with the next generation instruments we
hope to be able to tease out that first
ring
and that will be a much stronger test of
gravity because the light that does a
u-turn around the black hole spends more
time
in that highly curved space time
so the stuff
the photons that make it to us have a
lot more information
about whether that space-time conforms
to einstein's theory or whether we have
to find a new theory
um can we go back to what we talked
about on your first visit on the into
the impossible podcast i'll put a link
to that conversation up here over here
somewhere
and that was uh about the next
generation um
surely you know any reasonable funding
agency uh would see these results
including the m87 results uh from three
years ago and now these as harbingers of
incredible new science that's uh
uniquely capable by this instrument and
this instrument alone first of all you
know i've been told the best thing in
business is to have a monopoly do you
guys have a monopoly is there any other
team that can do what you guys do um and
so is there or is there not an
alternative for the nsf and the eso and
so forth to upgrade and build a bigger
better version of ng uh eht
well so what i would say is that there
are a lot of there are some different
views on how to proceed
uh to enhance the eht
but the one that has been you know
endorsed by the national science
foundation
and the one that was written up in the
uh decatur review that just came out
this is this naval gazing exercise that
all of us astronomy engages in every 10
years
and and they wrote that the next
generation concept that we put forward
is is viable and should proceed
so we're damning the torpedoes like
we're just full steam ahead to do this
and uh you know
observing at multiple frequencies adding
different colors to our palette
when we
image these black holes winding the
bandwidth with bigger sensitivity
um hold on one second yeah i know you
have to go soon
uh no i'm just have to uh
yeah
uh you're doing all these things and
building out new telescopes
that's gonna that's a very
robust path ahead and we already
are working with private foundations and
the nsf to do that
um
i really just see no
showstopper here i think that we should
set our sights on 2030 make high dynamic
range images of m87 to show the energy
extraction from the black hole through
the jet
and on sagittarius a star to capture the
dynamics during a single night and test
einstein's theory by looking at orbits
of matter
these are
the questions that will motivate
us
physics astronomy even
history philosophy and mathematics for
the coming decade oh for certain what
about adding new bass lines i mean if
you put one at the north pole if you put
one in space what are the limits to uh
the resolution both in space and time
and frequency of uh the current uh suite
of instruments and then think big 100
years from now what could you imagine we
could do
uh with a next next generation eht
yeah so i'll i'll have to go after this
because i'm being being raptured sure
you have a busy day yeah
but
uh
so
the magic of interferometry
is that the number of baselines you can
use the number of connections between
antennas
uh each and each each single pair gives
you one data point that that number of
pairs goes as n squared so it's
quadratic so every time you add a new
dish you get many more bass lines it
grows
very very fast so even by adding six new
dishes for example we would triple
the amount of data that we're going to
get and if we were to add
you know
many more sites than that we would again
go up by a factor of three so that by
2030 we should be 10 times
more capable than we are now now that's
a new telescope anytime you have an
order of magnitude you've broken through
a certain barrier
so so when you ask about new baselines
that really is the trick if you're
filling in the earth size virtual lens
that'll take us to the next step
that's unbelievable shep i want to thank
you and give you congratulations a
hearty congratulations to you your team
your friends in europe and asia all
around the world this is a worldwide
effort and we need it more than ever i
mean you think about what unites people
and what divides people who cannot fail
to be just moved blown away and excited
about the future the future of
technology human capital and these
resources that you and your team have
spectacularly unlocked thank you so much
chef for sharing your time i know you've
got a huge day ahead of you
congratulations my friend we'll talk
again soon
okay bye brian take care my friend bye
bye